Fox News contributor Joey Jones and Fox
News contributor former CIA station
Chief Dan Hoffman Dan will start with
you you're the Intel expert what does
China likely thinking uh I'll never
forget when we were in Singapore and
Vietnam you gave me a lot of dire
warnings about China
yeah look Taiwan sits on the
geopolitical fault line between
democracy and dictatorship and it's a
very dangerous place for us to be if
we're not giving them all the support
they need back in February director
burns from the CIA said that China was
planning to have the capability to
invade Taiwan in by 2027. China
considers Taiwan a breakaway Province
even though they've never ruled it and
the challenge I think for the United
States is that we've got to give Taiwan
more of what they need to make it
prohibitively costly for China in terms
of spilled blood and treasure learn from
from what happened in Ukraine where we
failed to deter Vladimir Putin let's try
to do what we can to to deter the
Chinese that means giving Taiwan a lot
of what we should be giving more of to
Ukraine Javelin anti-tank weapons Joey
can speak to this more than I but
Coastal air defense all the things that
Taiwan needs get them the F-16 aircraft
that they need as well yeah Joey let's
get your take on all of this and and
your assessment of the the real clear of
what I view as a present danger
yeah I think that what American people
need to understand is China's never
changed their terminology or outlook on
this they've just been waiting until
they had the strength and opportunity to
act on it I mean we saw it happen in
Hong Kong uh you know we took out their
biggest enemy in Japan World War II we
took out their next biggest threat with
the fall of the Soviet Union the USSR
and what has been in their way ever
since not much of anything especially
not us as far as our ability to help
Taiwan I agree with Dan that is that is
the most obvious path forward but I mean
the American people have to sit here and
say are we willing to fund with either
treasure or blood two Wars at the same
time with two countries we don't
actually have a mutual defense treaty
with and that's the problem that
American politicians have put us in it
makes a lot of sense to defend Taiwan
but we're currently going through a
complete restructuring of the United
States Marine Corps in the Pacific
that's looking to take eight years to
create littoral forces that would allow
us to defend our own backdoor against
China how are we going to arm Taiwan if
it's going to take us a decade to arm
ourselves it seems to me like there's a
lot of mismanagement or at least on lack
of ability between Congress and our
military leaders to be prepared for what
is the threat in front of us you know
even Marine Corps generals that are
retired are very much in dispute with
the current Marine Corps generals
leading the Marine Corps on this plan
because we basically had to sell out all
of our land finding capabilities in
order to pay for what is an eight-year
plan to defend the Pacific so we're not
in a great place with our own military
and how many men and women are going to
send their sons and daughters to defend
another country and I'm not saying they
should or shouldn't I'm saying that's
where the American taxpayer is and as
far as our ability to fund a war that's
my ability that's your ability that's
the taxpayers ability let me ask you the
final question keep creating and funding
War
final question for both of you do you
think if China invades Taiwan that
America under Joe Biden will lift a
finger I don't believe we he will I
don't think he'll do a darn thing he'll
talk about sanctions this and that I
don't think he's going to do anything
militarily Dan Hoffman
well I'll turn the question around a
little bit Sean what matters is what
China believes if they don't believe
that the United States is ready to step
in and defend Taiwan that will enter
into their calculus just one thing for
people to think about let's assume it
happens do you think Joe Biden will act
I don't think he will
I do actually believe the administration
would act I think there'd be a lot of
pressure coming from the Congress and I
think there's bipartisan consensus from
Democrats and Republicans Sean it's like
the only thing we can find where
Democrats and Republicans actually agree
with China over Taiwan is that you
really think that's going to happen
because I'm not laughing about it I'm
not you know I'm talking about our sons
and daughter our national treasure here
well we're talking about losing a lot of
National Treasure if China subsumes
taiwan's economy and that semiconductor
industry that's so important to us not
to mention the fact that it's you know
the same uh the same reason we're
helping Ukraine that that to allow a
nuclear-armed state to take over another
but look a good debate to have Joey
makes good points about spilling our own
blood and treasure in a far away place
my relatives did that in the Second
World War uh and that's kind of what we
do you know we go out there in the hard
places and defend our country's
interests
if China does invade Taiwan do you think
Joe Biden lifts a finger short of
sanctions and a lot of rhetoric
Sean you could have asked me if I
thought Joe Biden would surrender
Afghanistan and let dozens of us die to
do it and I'd have said no way he was
vice president for eight years that why
would he do that and that's exactly what
he did I have no idea how he had respond
to Taiwan but I know if he didn't
respond in any way his political career
would be over because he's promised to
respond for the last six months uh Joey
thank you Dan Hoffman thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else